[Music]
the process of prosthetics is something
i don't think people are quite aware
with how extensive it is it's such a
complex
department and the build that goes into
these things is quite time consuming
from seeing our actor come to our studio
and we take a head cast of them
sticking a makeup on on set is you know
it's quite a long build time
but i think what's what's great for us
is that it's lovely to see all our hard
work
and all these things we've built
actually make it to the screen as well
at the end of the day
[Music]
just an average prosthetic makeup we
usually say it's like about four to six
weeks to build
we have so many patient actors that sit
in our chair for like
four six or eight hours at a time
so by the time we usually step on set to
do a rehearsal we've already pretty much
done a full day's work
so to then film and have our fun on set
making sure everything's not falling off
people for 12 hours
the d-rig in the evening can take a good
um an hour you know or two hours
[Music]
people are quite unaware of the length
of time and the process that goes into
these things
so each year it's got bigger and bigger
and bigger
to the point now with season eight we're
we're sort of maxing numbers about the
70 or 80 mark on set
and in the workshop we usually have a
team of about 50 people
it's a big department to manage i think
we're very fortunate to have accumulated
a really talented sort of pool of
prosthetic people
i got hired season four we only had six
whites
uh filming and these are these green
screen guys and at the time that was a
that was a huge thing for us at the time
cut to hard home the following year
where it just exploded
we had something like about 40 to 50
prosthetic guys out there
at any one time applying the whites and
white walkers
when we found out two years ago there's
only 13 episodes left
i think we were obviously gutted and
distraught
but i think it's it's it's real
testament to the guys that they
stuck to the word and they're basically
finishing the franchise when it should
naturally end it's become such a huge
part of our life now i think
finishing next year and moving on to
other projects
is really daunting
[Music]
i think it's probably scary for a lot of
folk because we've just become part of
this
incredible family
the end is nigh but i think it's uh it's
going to be a big end
[Music]
hey everybody it's charlie surprise game
of thrones season 8 promo from hbo
more behind the scenes stuff a little
bit of white walkers they mixed in a
tiny bit of new footage from season 8.
it also seems like hbo has revealed the
final run times for each of the last
episodes there are six episodes total
during season eight so we'll break it
all down there's a new round of the book
giveaway all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on the video most of this promo that we
get is just them talking about
primarily the white walkers like a lot
of this is just the whites the white
walkers and the night king behind the
scenes across the last couple of seasons
and how that's changed they're just
talking about
how much crazier the army of the dead
has gotten season to season
one of the cooler things though about
some of this behind the scenes is from
way back during season 4 episode 4 when
we were in the lands of always winter
watching the night king turn one of
craster's sons into a white walker
this is one of those things that george
r martin hasn't spent a lot of time in
the books talking about yet
and one of the big differences between
the books and the tv show
is that in the books right now there is
no night king in present day that
they've spoken of the closest thing that
we have to a book version of the night
king is the night's
king as in plural nights not just
singular night and he was the 13th lord
commander
supposedly a stark of winterfell but the
way george r martin has explained that
version of the night king is that he was
a hero of legend that died off a long
time ago the tv show's version of the
night king is a completely different
story
the history of the world the blood raven
is a little bit different too
because they didn't really get into the
idea of the blood raven on the tv show
and the bloodraven is the three-eyed
raven or becomes the three-eyed raven he
was one of the many bastard sons of
aegon targaryen
iv during the blackfyre rebellion era he
was on the small council for a little
while
he lived a very full life before he took
the black then he was at the wall for a
long time before he headed north to the
wall to answer the call of the children
of the force and become the three-eyed
raven
so it'll be interesting to see if the tv
show incorporates any of the myths and
legends about the 13th lord commander
night's king that was a stark of
winterfell they've been a lot better
about doing these extended promos and
behind the scenes and little
documentaries for the episodes the last
couple of seasons they didn't do
quite as much during the first couple of
seasons so it's always fun to see stuff
from earlier on the show and then
obviously all the behind the scenes that
you see from hard home
was the different actor playing the
night king then by the time you get to
all that season six
behind the scenes when they're in
episode five at the three-eyed ravens
tree all this stuff here
we get to the vladimir furtick version
of the night king i just did a preview
video for his character because he did a
really big interview talking about
what his goals are as the night king
during season eight the very specific
targets that he has that he wants to
kill so i'll link that video at the end
of this
the even bigger news though just to talk
about the episode links specifically so
apparently hbo's scheduling website just
revealed these
we don't have all the episode titles or
episode descriptions for the later stuff
but we do know
the links they have posted that so
episode 1 is going to be 54 minutes
episode 2 58 minutes episode 3
60 minutes full hour episode 4 is where
we start to get a little bit longer
78 minutes episode 5 is going to be 80
minutes in episode 6
the finale series finale will be 80
minutes which if that doesn't sound very
long that's about how long the season
seven finale was
so just to compare this to the episode
run times for season seven
this is what they were so even though
we're getting fewer episodes the actual
total run time of season eight is pretty
close to season seven just about 30
minutes less
remember last year there was a rumor
that episodes were going to be super
super long and then just a little while
ago at the tcas
hbo and casey boyce came out and said no
no no try to dispel all those rumors
they're going to be much closer to time
and time is what you would call a normal
episode for hbo which is like a little
under an hour long because they don't
have commercials so just looking at each
of the individual episodes
episode 1 is 54 minutes that's a little
bit shorter than season 7 episode 1
dragonstone but pretty close
episode 2 also just a little bit shorter
but almost the exact same length as
season 7 episode 2.
episode 3 is going to be the third
battle of winterfell that's going to be
their episode long battle
the entire episode will just be that
giant battle that we're seeing in the
trailers
the closest parallel to that during
season seven is actually episode four in
the field of fire which is really just
the last part of that episode you just
have to imagine an entire episode that's
just that big battle with the dothraki
in the lannisters
episode four is another david nutter
directed episode so obviously that's
going to be the aftermath of the battle
potential destruction of winterfell then
them potentially turning their sights to
what's happening with cersei
the golden company in king's landing
which i think will be a much bigger
thing the second half of the season
after they've dealt with his first big
battle with the white walkers
i know there's still a lot of questions
about what's happening with the army of
the dead the night king the white
walkers
and what's happening in king's landing
because it would be a huge twist
if they dealt with the army of the dead
the first half of the season but there's
still ways to explain
how the army of the dead is largely
eradicated
but the night king or white walkers
survived to make it down to king's
landing to replenish their ranks
before the end of the season i wouldn't
expect too much of a big battle to
happen in episode 4 because episode 5
is another miguel sapochnick directed
episode that's going to be an hour 20
minutes long
there will probably be some form of
battle at king's landing during that
episode with the golden company
but it's an hour and 20 minutes long
remember like one of the longest
episodes that the series has ever had
the longest so far was the season seven
finale which is 80 minutes and so that
means that the last two episodes of
season eight are going to be the exact
same length so those will be like your
small movies
episode six the series finale is
directed by dan and dave i'm not
expecting any really huge battle or
anything like that because that's not
really their specialty i think it'll be
mostly character work in wrapping up all
these story lines
i've already done a couple videos about
what the actors have said about the
series finale and what i think is going
on with the characters but we'll do more
as we get more footage
but i think most of the promos they
release the next couple of weeks before
the season starts will be footage from
the first
part of the season but there will be
more trailers before the season gets
here so no worries
it's just that right now they're leaning
so hard on that big
episode three battle that i think that
most of the footage is gonna swirl
around that because they want you to
think that they're to kill off a whole
bunch of those big characters at
winterfell
so let me know in the comments what do
you think is going to happen with the
night king in the white walkers
after the big battle at winterfell
during episode 3.
do you think the night king will survive
and then try to go down to king's
landing
and turn a whole bunch of more people
and there'll be another battle with
white walkers down there where do you
think it's gonna be a big twist they
take care of the night king during
episode three
then by episode four they go down south
and it's still a big battle but cersei
is the bigger villain than the night
king at that point they've been leaning
on the night king and the army of the
dead as villains for the last couple of
seasons
so hard that it would be a ned stark
season one level swerve
if they killed him off halfway through
the season then just proceeded to turn
cersei into an even bigger villain
the way that lena heady talked about
cersei's storyline during season eight
says that she's sort of trapped herself
in a prison of her own making with the
deals that she's made with euron the
golden company in the iron bank so she's
sort of teasing this comeuppance like
cersei will eventually have to pay her
debts like lannister always pays their
debts
and there's a bunch of people in line
waiting to collect primarily
euron standing at the front in the iron
bank standing right next to him
so it'll be funny to see how she tries
to keep the wolves quote unquote at bay
because she has
jon snow the actual metaphorical wolves
from the north coming because the north
remembers but also she has these sort of
terrible people that she's put herself
in bed with so to speak euron actually
really wanting to bed her
and marry her to become king but post
all your theories in the comments below
what'll happen is is there'll be new
game of thrones later this week i'll
name a giveaway winner when i post that
but leave all your video requests in the
comments below there'll be more promos
like this posting in the next couple of
weeks
while you wait for everything click here
for my preview of the night king in the
white walkers during season 8
and click here for a bunch of really big
easter eggs from the game of thrones
season 8 trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight